what is going on guys welcome to my PI
to exe tutorial video in this video I'm
going to be showing you guys the module
PI to exe the purpose here is really as
the name sounds is to take your Python
files and turn them in and executables
but that's not the only reason you can
also use this to distribute your Python
applications and the users using them
won't need to have Python installed to
run them or even your modules right that
you are used by your Python application
now for the most part it's a pretty
smooth operation to convert anything to
a exe file but there are some modules
that might require a little bit of fancy
footwork and then also there might be a
little bit of moving some dll's around
or something like that Bo cover that and
a little bit at the end of the video and
then I'll also probably have a follow-up
video that showing the full conversion
of something like my Python charting
application which is a large application
also using matplotlib which is kind of
finicky with PI to exe that full
conversion but for now we're just going
to do the basics so the first thing
we're going to do is go ahead and grab
PI to exe so we can actually install it
so here's our home page when you get
here you can click on download and it
takes you here and you can see actually
they've done us a lid here and they've
given us all just dot exe downloads you
can get the MSI if you want but
otherwise just download either the 64
bit or the 32 bit 4 to 7 or whatever
version you have I'm going to be using
Python 2 7 so that's what we'll cover
once you've downloaded and installed
that make sure you do a quick check to
make sure that you actually did
everything right so open up your command
prompt around I'm starting and from your
python command line and just make sure
you can do import PI to e X E and as
long as you can do that with no errors
you're good to go so let's go ahead and
take it further and let's build a
program that we want to use and convert
to an exe file so just to show like some
of the cool things where you can import
I'll say time so we'll do that
and we're going to have some functions
here so we'll say define insane fun for
like the craziest function you've ever
seen
x equals raw input and in here it will
say I there what is your name
so obviously raw input kind of like a
Python function also time is the way we
orient things is you know Python
specific pretty much and then this
function will just return X they're
going to have a main and y equals insane
funk and then we're going to have it
print hello Y and then print check it
out time module works and then finally
we will do time sleep five and then it
will close out because this will
basically run in your command prompt
console and then finally we do need to
call main at the end of this so that's
it so this is going to be the file that
we want to run now the next thing that
we're going to do is in the same
directory we want to have a setup high
file so I'll just copy this I'm going to
call this set up and then let's edit it
and here it is and keep in mind this is
our setup PI file I just made a copy and
paste so that's why I'm deleting
everything here but yet don't delete
your file that you just made right now
within here all you need to do is you
need to specify some stuff you've ever
made a setup PI file it's kind of like
that right you need to make you give it
some parameters
so from this utils C did we get this
detail dot core import setup and then we
want to import PI to exp and then we're
going to say setup and in here console
equals and then in square brackets you
give the file name and for us we're
going to do pi 2px e1 PI and or actually
let's see what we do in PI to exe Tut
is what I named you mission you get all
the spelling right on there pi to exit
touch okay and that's it with your setup
that PI file now close out that and the
next thing you need to do is actually
run the setup so it's a lot like doing
any other setup pi only there's a couple
left one major difference so now what
you want to do is open up your command
prompt like cmd.exe and bring that over
and now what you want to do is change
directory right into wherever your self
dot pi file is so mine will be CD
desktop slash desktop slash cindex
lessons let me make sure we can get
there yeah
CD pi to exe / pi to e XD - hmm now
we're in there so make some more space
so you can see the full line let's
hoping I could but okay now what we want
to do is Python setup PI and normally
you say install here but now we do PI to
e x e and it would be all on one line
but we just went over it slowly and I
can't seem to make the window any larger
so now when you hit Enter
do that hopefully you get no errors a
lot of stuff flies by but you should
have had two new directories made here
now just as a quick aside sometimes
you'll get like a DLL error it will say
it doesn't have that DLL chances are you
have that DLL and so if it says it says
something like that I'll cover that in
just a second but first let's show the
finished product here so I'm going to
close out of our command prompt and
within dist you should have an exe of
your python script so let's go ahead and
double click on that comes up sure
enough we get this window here what's
your name you can put your name my name
is Harrison hello
it says hello Harrison check out the
time module works and then in a few
seconds this goes away right so simple
programs you know simple executable but
at least it shows you that you know the
modules will work and the Python works
and every every way that you would have
hoped so really
cool module this pi2 vxe now as I said
sometimes you can have a little bit of a
screw-up where it's as if you're missing
a dll especially with some modules that
are written in C or UC and what you'll
need to do is you can just find like if
you're on Windows you go to the search
type in that DLL you at least in my case
I've always had the DLL and type it in
and then go to your python directory
like in my case it's in c python 2 7
right and right e somewhere here dll is
right you have this dll directory and
like for me it said we I didn't have the
PI wind types I've also had it say I
didn't have this mcvp and then this one
was also an issue but I did have them I
just needed a search for it in my
computer and just click and drag or copy
and paste it into this dll's you can
also download most of these dll's off
the internet but you really don't need
to you probably have them on your
computer if you were using that module
so anyway that's that that's the basics
to PI 2 Exe it's a really neat program
and it will allow you to make and
distribute applications and not have to
have people using Python or downloading
Python and all that so a great great
thing that that you can have within
Python so anyway hopefully that's useful
for some of you guys hopefully you
enjoyed as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time